wir schreiben den heutigen tag 7 uhr 23
am morgen sonntag morgen und es hat 98
da der erste eine million abonnenten
macht es nicht so spannend
es wird noch ein einziger metzger
hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video
ich glaube das war zwar schon mega hier
ein ziemlich fröhlich gerade auf gestand
ich habe eine stimme 20 und
hochkompetent jetzt geht es nach
österreich alter woher hast du das ja so
wenig zu schlafen
ich habe mir gerade huber bestätigt das
ist nämlich zum hauptbahnhof ich gebe
jetzt einmal über deutschland eine
chance gestern war das wieder so eine
scheiße ich habe 15 euro bezahlt für nix
das war irgendwie so ein technischer
defekt das auto kam nie als das tut mir
auch der auf der karte nicht angezeigt
ganz komisch wurden jetzt hoffentlich
glaube dass jetzt muss es klappen sonst
richtung zu geben ich nicht ich war
jetzt zusammen mit mats mit dem treffe
ich mich um 4 uhr fahren mit dem zug
nach salzburg glaub nicht und ich mache
dieses video aus folgendem grund und
zwar bin ich eben pendlern
ich habe jetzt mal kurz hier rein leute
hier könnte ich sehen 990 1955 ich hätte
eigentlich schon meine eine million
gehabt das problem weil ich habe es
natürlich die position der eine million
haben und dann kriegt das handy dann
habe ich direkt 200 läutete abonniert
dann bin ich begangen habe
da hab ich kein bock möchte um zu sitzen
aber wir kommen der sache immer näher
und ich denke es ist gleich soweit im
zug dann wahrscheinlich deswegen fühle
mich das jetzt ich nehme euch mit der
sache sind gepackt und das auto ist auf
dem weg hin
also wir sehen uns gleich spätestens am
bahnhof
so leute angekommen dom ich hoffe ihr
könnt nicht der halter hier laufen auch
gestalten um nach zehn jahren eine kurze
hose
dabei sind schaufenster an eine sagt ich
würde sagen wollte schau dich mal voll
im nebel dass ich glaube ich bin ein
bisschen früher da als der max den muss
ich jetzt erst mal suchen oder auf ihn
warten und dann geht's ab und zu gehe
ich bin auf jeden fall noch ziemlich
kalt und der mann das safe mit kurzer
hose
ich war noch nie so früh glaube ich naja
ist gleich mit noch eine schöne musik
ist schon ein großer batzen es auch
schon dabei und jetzt 520 euro
das ding ich kann mich jetzt gar nicht
richtig freuen weil ich erstens müde bin
zweitens sind wir überall menschen
obwohl ich um eine konfettikanone
rucksack dabei würde gleich dazu kommen
hier kann man 10 990 1980 und wir haben
jetzt gerade 54 58
die jungen die eine meldung
wir schreiben in dem heutigen tage 7 uhr
23 am morgen am sonntagmorgen und es hat
da der erste eine million abonnenten
macht es nicht so spannend
das wird noch ein einziger let's go
kamen
oh mein gott wir haben die einst einer
noch mit dazu gezahlt
wenn man so früh morgens
naja da dauert wir haben sieben uhr 26
leute
und jetzt
hatte die eine million
jetzt zog der übertrieben hat
übernachtung
ich schreibe wir das fest klingt das
fest nicht verwerten
so wird es geht das ist jetzt alles ein
bisschen provisorisch hier schon in der
unterstufe angekommen ich habe das video
gerade fertig geschnitten als kommt so
rüber wie das würde mich gar nicht
darüber freuen dass ich persönlich habe
ich mich gefreut war nicht ich glaube
ich kann es doch nicht so zeigen lassen
das war menge früh und es ist einfach so
man realisiert dass noch gar nicht aber
es kommt auf jeden fall noch ein video
wo ich ausführlich darüber erzähle und
ich habe mich wirklich sehr gefreut also
ich freue mich immer noch richtig
deutsch fragment das jetzt so sehr dass
er eine million steht ich habe das so
lange darauf hingearbeitet vielen vielen
dank an jeden ist etwas ganz besonderes
für mich und jetzt seht ihr noch nicht
ob und wann haben sie in die voll geld
aus ihren stimmt nicht sind nicht gelten
dass ohne kleider und schuhe und ich
weiß nicht wie du weißt doch nicht auf
und ich hab halt gerade keine
möglichkeit das irgendwie auf mich
zuschneiden gegen es auf jeden fall
feiern und viel spaß mit der kleinen
kultur brauchen 19 kommt auf ein
geheimes video das von produziert genau
so leute wir sind jetzt gerade wir kommt
vom skifahren gestern habe ich gar
nichts mehr gefilmt aber es war
eigentlich auch nur einen block weil ich
ja in diesem blog die eine million
erreicht hat und ich das halt festhalten
wollte deswegen an alle die jetzt noch
dran geblieben sind kurze jugend uhr von
der location die wir haben und dann gehe
ich duschen es ist so gerade noch ein
bisschen hält deswegen gehe ich mal
schnell raus hier sieht man so einfluss
wir sind hier in zell am see nennt sich
das vielleicht kennt ihr das ja das ist
eine heftig steller fluss und da sind an
die berge da hinten ist irgendwie unser
skigebiet und wir sind heute gerade
wieder gekommen und dann kann man hier
noch zusammen abendessen wenn man gerne
in der kälte sitzt also keine ahnung ist
wahrscheinlich für den sommer
so hier kommt man rein wo genau da wird
dass diese auf ecke viel spaß
und obwohl eigentlich was keinen spaß
hier kann man dann abends gemütlich
zusammensitzen und wieder hier sind dann
irgendwelche zimmer von felix magath
könnte ja wahrscheinlich erstmal nichts
und hier ist auch noch einmal mein
zimmer ist aber woanders zeigen und zwar
ist das hier zum beispiel mein bett
leute das war's dann eigentlich auch
schon wer wollte ich eigentlich sagen
ich geh jetzt duschen wie gesagt ist ein
grad gefallen wieder hinkommen
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen lassen
denken doch nach oben da und wir sind es
dann morgen um 19 uhr wieder da gibt es
nämlich ein ganz normales cooles video
kommt rein
instagram alex w aber wer trotzdem den
kanal auf mehr als eine million sind
haut rein